bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
émission qui va tenter de vous expliquer
comment un effet de levier peut se
transformer en coup de massue
bonjour à tous et bienvenue fille dans
ces caches bonjour olivier fillon va
commencer avec une devinette pour vous
elle peut provenir d'un ménage d'un état
ou d'une entreprise elle est souvent
perçue comme très négatif en france elle
devrait atteindre à la fin de l'année
plus de 115% du pib de quoi parle-t-on
olivier d'écouté joly c'est pas parce
que 115 pour semble paraît très faible
par rapport à la réalité mais je pense
que ça doit être la dette on va parler
de la dette bien sûr et on va en parler
à dans cette émission et plus
particulièrement de son rapport à la
croissance la dette était l'ami ou
l'ennemi de la croissance c'est cette
question qui va nous occuper ces vingt
prochaines minutes et pour en parler
nous sommes aussi avec un pierre
sabatier économiste membre d econoclaste
et présidente du cabinet primeview
bienvenue dans ses cages pierre sabatier
bonjour estelle bonjour olivier un jour
plein elle était initialement estimés à
118 % du pib à la fin de l'année 2021 il
ne sera finalement sans doute que 215 3
% en 2022 la dette de la france devrait
reculer légèrement pour s'établir à 113
5 % du pib du côté de la croissance elle
pourrait tutoyer les 7% en fin d'année
alors la dette est elle réellement
mauvaise pour la croissance éléments de
réponse avec le tiroir cachés dans un
sas
[Musique]
s'il ya bien un rapport qui divise les
économistes c'est celui entre dead et
croissance la dette était l'ami ou
l'ennemi de la croissance il a dix ans
deux professeurs de finance américain
kenneth rogoff et carmen reinhart publié
un best-seller cette fois c'est
différent me siècle de foggy financière
en analysant la récurrence avec laquelle
les pays riches comme les pays pauvres
sans dette jusqu'à ce que crise
financière s'en suive il pose est une
règle simple passé un certain seuil de
dette 90 % du pib une décroissance
inéluctable s'enclenche la dette serait
donc l'ennemi de la croissance mais leur
thèse a depuis été remises en cause par
d'autres universitaires surtout que la
situation aujourd'hui
comprenez poste que vider poste
quoiqu'il en coûte n'est plus la même
qu'il ya dix ans prenez la dette
française selon les dernières prévisions
elle devrait atteindre à la fin de cette
année sans 15,3 pour cent du pib puis
descendre à 113,5 % en 2022 et pourtant
même si on sait que nous sommes en plein
rebond économique après une récession de
plus de 8 % en 2020 la croissance
frôlerait les 7 % cette année selon l'
ocde un record et atteindrait 4,2 pour
cent en 2022 la règle au des 90 % de
dette publique engrangeant de la
décroissance semble donc un peu bancal
dans ce contexte post co vide selon
michel girardin professeur à
l'université de genève il faudrait en
plus de la dette porter attention à la
charge de la dette sont qu'un pays doit
dépenser chaque année pour rembourser sa
dette tant que la charge est basse et
même si la dette est massive comme au
japon par exemple
la croissance pourrait continuer ce
serait en fait la conjonction du niveau
d'endettement et de la charge d'intérêt
qu'il faudrait considérer et pas
seulement la dette
[Musique]
ça vous fait sourire ce qu'on a entendu
d'en rendre le tireur cash oui il ya
beaucoup de choses qui me françois
d'abord le niveau de la dette on est on
est malheureusement très très loin des
115 on est très au dessus des 115 %
puisque c'est le grand jeu assez basse
ce qu'on appelle la comptabilité
créatrice qui vous permet de virer un
peu de stock de dettes et puis de leur
appartient un petit peu partout et
surtout pas le couper donc
vous êtes très au dessus mais ça c'est
tous les pays un vous êtes très au
dessus en fait de 115% sur sur le la
dette française comme vous l'êtes au
dessus dans d'autres pays comme aux
états unis et autres puisque on ne
comptabilise pas tout est loin de là ça
c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose c'est
je ne sais plus quel est le nom du de
l'universitaire enfin je peux vous en
citer à l'appel comme ça qui vous
expliquent que la dette de toute façon
c'est pas c'est pas grand chose que
c'est pas grave que un jour on pourra
l'effacer
vous avez gaël giraud spécialiste de
genre de plaisanterie et enfin et c'est
là donc vous en avez beaucoup qui vous
explique que de toute façon c'est pas
grave pourquoi ils vous expliquent que
de toute façon c'est pas grave parce
qu'aujourd'hui aucun politique ne sais
faire
moi je vais vous expliquer quand vous
avez une dette normalement vous devez la
rembourser alors il ya la charge de la
dette oui en effet si les intérêts de la
dette sont plus élevés eh bien vous avez
encore plus de mal à larmor c mais
aujourd'hui je vous ai expliqué
plusieurs fois qu'on avait en fait
remplacé l'activité on a remplacé du
chiffre d'affaires par de la dette eh
bien allez dire ça à chef d'entreprise
il va vous regarder bizarrement et il
aura raison de vous regarder bizarrement
c'est à dire que à un moment il va
falloir quand même la rembourser c'est
ce que disait pierre à propos des pg
quand vous allez à voir avec une active
tu es qui sera somme toute peut-être
même pas revenu au niveau de d'avant
quand vous allez avoir à rembourser la
dette le nominal de la dette d'accor eh
bien il va falloir quand même sortir des
sous et c'est là justement ça peut peser
et c'est là que justement on peut avoir
un petit problème au moment du
remboursement des pg e parce
qu'aujourd'hui on se félicite qu'il n'y
ait pas eu de faillite comme on les
avait prévu bien évidemment on continue
allez on continue à leur donner de
l'argent et surtout on leur réclament
pas de rembourser ce que ce qu'on leur a
donné donc ils peuvent continuer comme
ça pendant un moment donc sur le sur le
la dette c'est ridicule de dire que
finalement c'est pas bien grave parce
que les taux d'intérêt sont sont à zéro
pourquoi d'abord les taux d'intérêt sont
à zéro parce que la banque centrale fait
en sorte d'administrer les prix pour que
les taux d'intérêt restent à zéro parce
qu'elle sait très bien que si à un
moment ait laissé faire les choses et
que les taux remonter bien ce moment-là
sacré une catastrophe donc aujourd'hui
on continue à s'endetter et c'est même
devenu un modèle économique et ça depuis
une quinzaine d'années où vous avez le
la croissance qui n'est que la
croissance de la dette en fait c'est à
dire que vous allez mettre 12 euros sur
la table pour obtenir 1 euro de plus 1
de pib évidemment alors vous êtes tous
contents parce que vous avez obtenu un
euro de plus de pib le problème c'est
que les 12 euros il va falloir à un
moment les rembourser et donc à ce
moment-là ça pèsera sur la croissance
donc on le voit très bien vous avez
l'exemple japonais l'exemple japonais
qui depuis 30 ans pratiquent cette dette
avec des déficits budgétaires qui sont 7
à 10% par an et vous n'avez pas de
croissance au japon depuis 30 ans donc
probablement c'est que il doit y avoir
une interaction entre la dette et la
croissance
japon justement en plus tard dans cette
émission pierre sabatier l'epg
effectivement pour les évoquer elle
c'était la semaine dernière dans notre
précédente émission concrètement est-ce
que vous pouvez nous expliquer quel
impact quel est le lien de causalité
entre la dette et la croissance
c'est vrai que alors olivier un sourire
moi j'emploierai presqu'un d'avoir ce
genre de débat hier que
parlons aux gens les gens ils sont plus
vraiment plus rationnelle que les
autorités publiques en général quelle
qu'elle soit verte les gens ils
comprennent que lorsqu'on a une
entreprise un outil de production soit
vous le fim enfin mots pour il faut
investir pour qu'elle génère du chiffre
d'affaires mais une fois que j'ai acheté
d'affaires vous allez payer tout le
monde mais elle l'a en fait on vous me
posez la question est ce que pour
générer plus de profit plus de richesse
créée est ce que c'est bon d'avoir
injecté encore plus en fait d'argent qui
ne m'appartient pas qui va falloir du
remboursement donner la réponse elle est
évidente privé l'évoqué certes il faudra
rembourser et le capital et la charge de
la dette ça c'est le premier point donc
évidemment en fait il ya un lien de
causalité c'est hier que quand vous
mettez plus de dettes vous allez générer
de la croissance encore heureux merkel
en plus candide la dette c'est quoi
c'est de la dépense publique soyons
précis la dépense le luxe et quoi on ne
l'évoqué la semaine dernière et bien
cédé petite béquille qu'on va donner aux
gens pour pouvoir et l'énergie qu'ils
qualifient de l'énergie les pays à une
société à total etc edf donc que vous
allez voir vous allez retrouver nishida
faire donc des profits réalisés par ces
gens-là dire que concrètement email
comprenez que lorsque vous ne faites de
la dette publique pour assumer des
dépenses publiques et plus de dépenses
milk de recettes fiscales que vous vous
que vous aimez que vous arrivé à lever
bien concrètement c'est logique que vous
le retrouvez dans la richesse créée mais
ce qui est stupéfiant et c'est ce qu'il
faut qualifier c'est le manque finale
profs pour tout ce qu'on a mis le si peu
de résultats mais c'est pathétique ça
qu'il faut avoir en tête c'est ça donc
donc il ya un lien de causalité évident
entre la dette que vous émettez à
l'année n et la croissance que vous
faites bien heureusement lorsque
d'arrière la dette c'est pas la dette tu
es la dépense publique c'est l'argent
vous donner aux gens aux gens ou aux
entreprises pour pouvoir dépenser les
collectivités locales c'est pareil quand
vous leur dites et bien vous allez avoir
fait de l'argent à disposition vous
allez pouvoir dépenser publiquement mais
quand vous refaites en fait votre
éclairage public il ya des gens qui vous
vendent des ampoules et des gens qui
viennent vous installer en fait le
pilote vous réinstaller le pilote qu'on
vous refaites une autre ya des gens qui
travaillent donc ça veut dire plus il ya
clairement la dépense publique alors si
on avait une économie qui vit qui était
suffisante pour générer suffisamment de
recettes fiscales pour faire face à des
dépenses publiques à la limite on
pourrait dire ça va merci de tout ça
c'est un jeu de vases communicants non
ça ne ça ne marche pas dire qu'il n'ya
pas assez de recettes fiscales
potentielles pays pour faire face à
toutes ses dépenses publiques donc on
s'endette donc la question fondamentale
c'est jusqu'à quand on peut s'endetter
sans que ça devienne létale et l'agent
vient en fait à l'intervention de votre
votre de l'universitaire suisse vous
évoquiez mais si la suisse est
remarquable à bien d'autres
là pour le coup je sais que c'est michel
girardin qui est un professeur à
l'université 2 michel le regard devient
problématique lorsque la charge
d'intérêt se révèle excessive l'adec
peut donc se révéler utile et être l'ami
de la croissance pour autant que le
service de la dette soit maîtrisé
l'homme est d'accord mais mêmes effets
magiques
l'imaginaire en france maîtrisent pas le
service de la dénommée nommer personne
maîtrise le sérieux la dette mettrait le
service de la tête ça voudrait dire que
d'une vie vous compreniez bien si on est
la situation on s'endette un moment
donné à taux fixe ok on s'endette sens
pour acheter son humiliant sa dpa brin
aujourd'hui ans en été on a acheté notre
l'immobilier puis après on va rembourser
pendant 20 ans ou 15 ans ou 20 ans en
fait chaque mois une partie du capital
une partie de la dette à taux fixe et
dire qu'on maîtrise la charge de la
dette hier quant aux les interviews
allait payer chaque mois ils sont
maîtrisés ou départ en fait faut que
vous compreniez que la gestion d'un état
c'est pas ça on les rembourse jamais
laissant imaginant la alors sans parler
ta tion de la dette mais d'une certaine
manière il faut que vous compreniez que
si on est à 100% dette publique chaque
année il ya 10% vous allez avoir
remboursé mais vous allez les substituer
par dix nouveaux % donc ça veut dire que
la charge de la dette à terme elle
dépend de l'évolution des taux
d'intérêts à terme vous ne pouvez pas
l'afficher quand vous êtes en état c'est
impossible si ce n'est à dire la banque
centrale sera toujours prête à me
financer à taux zéro mais est hélas
hélas ou faucon boucle absolument dans
cette émission pour dire qu'au final si
on fait ça donc vous avez compris qu'en
fait on peut pas maîtriser la chance de
la dette ça n'existe pas parce que le
stock de dette il vous paraît statique
il est dynamique il y en a un morceau
qui sort un morceau qui rentrent donc en
ce moment ce qui rentre d'un coup très
peu cher mais il n'est pas dit que ce
qui va rentrer en 2022 en 2023/2024 sera
toujours à taux zéro
et donc je vais même plus loin il ya
redire ça est grave parce que ça va
pousser à quoi ça va nous pousser à ne
plus avoir le choix là c'est le drame de
nos économies ne peut avoir le choix de
quoi de maîtriser de manière
administrative le niveau de taux
d'intérêt avec l'ia auquel on voit
finances à la dette ça c'est dangereux
parce a créé un aléa une moralité
colossal et à terme ça finit toujours
mal parce que lorsque mots les taux
d'intérêt sont à zéro non pour des
bonnes raisons mais parce que vous ne
pouvez plus faire autrement parce que
vos stock de dette fait que si jamais
les taux montent est bien à la charge de
la dette va vous exploser la figure et
dell va vous assassiner et vous voilà
elle va vous pousser en fait vers le
fond concrètement dont vous êtes obligés
de maintenir les taux à zéro et une
banque centrale et implémenter une
politique monétaire de taux zéro parce
qu'elle est obligée de le faire à cause
d'un stock de dette ça finit toujours
mal à savoir comment voulez vous faire
confiance dans un billet de banque n'est
pas autre chose qu'un contrat de
confiance entre quelqu'un qu'il possède
est quelqu'un qui y va l'accepter
contrecoup elle va vous livrer un bien
ou un service d'envoi une politique de
taux zéro une politique d'impression
monette est obligatoire pour financer
tout ça est qu'à terme ça vient dégrader
la confiance que feront les consignes
nos concitoyens dans la valeur de la
monnaie et à la fin ça fait que vossen
de dec peut-être vous rembourserai
toujours je vous assure mais si un
billet vaut plus rien vingt cinq fois
moins une pause qui valait et
concrètement ça on sera dans un régime
d'hyperinflation et les gens auront
perdu beaucoup donc c'est un jeu
dangereux à terme c'est qu'il faut
comprendre un plusieurs choses c'est le
service à la lettre c'est un jeu dans
lequel on s'est engagé depuis depuis un
moment et et on c'est pour ça que je
vous ai dit dix fois sur ce plateau eux
le leu leu les taux zéro et la politique
de planche à billets en fait était
irréversible parce qu'aujourd'hui ils ne
peuvent pas revenir en arrière ils sont
obligés de laisser les taux à zéro et
tout ce qu'il ya autour c'est à dire la
communication quand vous entendez madame
lagarde dire on va calmer le jeu sur les
achats de dettes extra c'est faux c'est
juste de la com parce qu'ils ne peuvent
pas ils sont contraints en plus il ya ya
ya un point sur lequel pierre à un
système est qu'il faut qu'il faut bien
comprendre quand vous quand vous générer
de la dette pour faire un investissement
wiki plus tard et la nature
effectivement nous rapporter de l'argent
ou en tout cas vous permettre d'en
économiser beaucoup et bien à ce moment
là la dette est intéressante si vous
voulez mais en revanche là on utilise de
la dette pour manger tous les jours si
vous voulez pas pour investir et donc
pour payer les dépenses publiques de
tous les jours de fonctionnement et à
partir de ce moment là vous savez que
vous n'allez pas générer plus tard de
l'argent avec cette dette
on vient dans un instant
bien né dans ces caches si vous nous
rejoignez au sommaire cette semaine le
rapport entre la dette et la croissance
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
pierre sabatier membres d econoclaste et
président du cabinet preview olivier
aujourd'hui en france la croissance
s'établit autour de 6 25% ça veut dire
que cette croissance est artificielle
elle est totalement artificielle c'est à
dire que déjà il faut savoir comment
comment on calcule un pib un pib c'est
la somme des valeurs ajoutées plus les
salaires des fonctionnaires en gros
donc déjà comprenez qu'il ya quelque
chose qui va pas avant le calcul
ensuite vous avez plein de manières de
faire en sorte que le pib sur un
trimestre soit important est que et
comme par hasard je pense que les
trimestre jusqu'à la fin de l'année vont
être bien je ne sais pas pourquoi mais
c'est une petite idée comme ça que que
j'ai et
façon le premier trimestre en avril pour
les élections ça sera plié on n'aura pas
les chiffres donc il vaut mieux que ça
soit bon jusque jusqu'au 31 décembre
donc le shiv sena chiffres que vous
prenez et puis vous demandez à l'insee
de vous calculer ça et de façon à ce que
ça colle aux résultats que vous lui avez
donné ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose c'est
c'est toujours la même chose c'est ce
qu'on voudrait c'est à dire que
je demandai je suis l'état je m'endette
donc en fait je nous endettent pour être
plus clair je nous endettent et je donne
l'ordre art bouygues ou à vinci de me
construire un rond point tous les 50
mètres d'accord alors ça va évidemment
fournir de l'activité oui il va pouvoir
sortir une valeur ajoutée un petit peu
plus importante et donc grossièrement
pipe sauf que ça vous rapporte quoi à la
fin rien d'accord donc vous avez
ponctuellement gonfler le pib 1
exactement comme on a eu pendant
plusieurs années en chine en chine où on
construisait des immeubles des villes
entières alors évidemment ça rentrait
dans le pipe et on vous disait à la
croissance extraordinaire oui sauf qu'il
n'y avait personne dans les villes parce
que personne n'était capable d'acheter
une fois qu'ils avaient construit
personne n'était capable de rentrer dans
les appartements et d'acheter les
appartements donc ça affine dette
colossale on l'a bien vu avec evergrande
ya pas très longtemps où ça a explosé en
vol mais c'est pour ça c'est parce que
là ça vous gêne r en fait un semblant de
pib mais qui n'est pas vraiment une
croissance je dirais autogénérés c'est
des donneurs d'ordre qui sont publiques
la plupart du temps et qui vous font
grossir encore une dette mais ça n'est
pas réellement de l'investissement
réellement de l'investissement ça aurait
été par exemple de construire une
centrale nucléaire ce qui nous aurait
permis de payer l'électricité moins
chère et là en effet c'est un vrai
investissement et là ça mérite de faire
de la dette si on n'a pas les sous pour
payer mais sinon ça n'a absolument aucun
intérêt est donc vous ponctuels mans
vous créer l'illusion d'une croissance
qui ne financent en fait n'est pas une
croissance air un mois après impôts à
présent lié vous l'évoquiez à tout à
l'heure le japon au début de l'année la
dette du pays a atteint 260 6% du pib
c'est colossal pourtant pierre sabatier
personnes ne sont vraiment sont
inquiétés et la croissance a tout de
même estimé d'ailleurs à travers les 3%
alors aujourd'hui ça me permet j'allais
dire j'allais revenir en arrière donc
j'allais être mal poli j'allais pas
répondre à votre question mais
méfiez-vous en fait les gens qui
viennent ici sont pas là pour
expliquer ses classiques n'est ce pas
tout ça pour dire mais + 3 % japon + 6 5
% en france mais j'ai l'impression avec
la clé du coup il arrange tout le monde
oui ça l'est encore plus à la veille à
la veille d'élections mais le + 6 % il
est la conséquence d'abord du moins 8 de
l'année dernière hier qu'un fai et plus
- 8 + 6 vous n'êtes toujours pas au
niveau d'avant car c'est fait attention
à d'une certaine manière l'essentiel au
delà même de qui fait les pluies 6%
cette année l'essentiel de la croissance
de cette année c'est un effet de base
positif hérité en fait de la chute de 1
précédentes ça correspond en rien au
niveau de croissance potentielle de la
france du japon des etats-unis de
partout dans le monde donc attention
tout de même lorsqu'on observe ces
chiffres ayant en tête que l'essentiel
de cette croissance là elle n'est pas
artificielle elle est conjoncturelle
elle est liée à la conjointe à une
conjoncture plus favorable que l'année
dernière parce qu'elle était déplorable
donc ça c'est vraiment l'élément de
fonds donc nous ne passons pas tant a
commenté un niveau de croissance ni en
france ni au japon ni aux états unis ça
ne sert à rien c'est les en fait
d'une chute colossale l'année passée ça
c'est le premier point le deuxième point
sur le lien entre niveau de dette
publique et et
soutenabilité soumis aux dettes
publiques alors premièrement au japon
n'y a pas de croissance et pas de
croissance depuis 25 ans donc nous ne
soyons pas dupes le + 3 % il vient en
fait de la chute de l'année d'avant a
plus il n'y a pas de croissance depuis
25 à 30 ans à c'est le premier point
deuxième point les prix de l'immobilier
ont pas beaucoup monté un pour les gens
qui sont japonais en fait vous savez que
les loyers sont imités ralement effondré
depuis les années 90 si on est très très
très très loin des niveaux atteints il
ya trente ans en est content pour
quelqu'un qui a investi à l'époque ça
c'est le deuxième point troisième point
c'est compliqué
ou avoir de l'humilité c'est compliqué
pourquoi c'est compliqué de savoir à
partir de quand ça s'arrête
c'est ce que j'évoquais je sais pas si
c'est dans cette émission on sait
d'avancé que ça s'arrête et et ccim
rogoff et reinhart dans le revenu qui
s'appelle système est différente qui
expliquait que en général ils ont pas
dit que c'était mais en général est qu
au delà de 90 % de dette publique peep
d'une aide publique ça en sa salsa
entraîner une récession n'y a pas
d'effet de cohabiter ils ont juste
observer que historiquement parlant sur
très très longue période lorsque la
dette publique est supérieure à gilbert
regarde le niveau de croissance et en
général c'est une récession parce que ça
devient insoutenable le problème de cela
c'est que donc c'est vrai en général
mais oui
mais c'est pas contredit ce n'est pas
une thèse c'est pas une thèse le livre
je peux vous le prêter si vous le
souhaitez tout vergnas je vous donnerai
pas
cbs inobservation historiquement lorsque
les états dépassent 90 % de dette
publique en constate qu'ils sont en
récession c'est pas parce qu'on a
constaté historiquement quelque chose
est arrivé que ça arrive forcément c'est
pas ça la thèse dire que le grosso modo
on observe simplement qu'il ya en
général un lien entre les deux juste
pour vous dire pourquoi c'est compliqué
c'est parce que
nous sommes rentrés parce qu'aujourd'hui
cette dette publique elle est financée
directement par la banque centrale
japonaise donc par une institution dans
un pays des cent dans sa cave imprime
les billets de banque à tour de bras les
donne à l'état pour financer son
économie et donc acheter la paix sociale
à travers le renouvellement des
ronds-points le renouvellement des ponts
même lorsqu'il est déjà neuf mais c'est
pas grave parce qu'on va donner de
l'emploi et c'est donc la vraie question
de fond c'est que à un moment donné mais
on ne sait jamais car c'est pour ça que
c'est difficile et ses complexes
abandonner si les japonais qui dirait
qui sonneront la fin de la récréation
parce qu'ils diront et bien finalement
cette masse monétaire en circulation ce
volume de billets en circulation dans
notre cas mais alors qu'on crée pas plus
de richesses que vaut-il bien si vous
avez 100 un nombre de billets en
circulation de sens et qu on le fait
passer à 200 alors qu'on crée pas plus
de richesses combien volumes y est lié
eh bien vous deux fois moins parce que
richesse créée par cinq eh bien ça vaut
deux fois plus plus riches est rédigé
par deux sens mais le problème c'est que
c'est ça c'est une prise de conscience
c'est vous en tant que consommateur qui
dit à un moment donné non mon billet en
fait touché plus tôt celui qui le reçoit
qu'il dit non non non j'en veux pas un
billet j'en veux 2 est donc cette
érosion monétaire à ce sympathique pas
les autres qui sonne nationale et
création c'est les ressentiments eux les
ressortissants eux mêmes d'un pays ils
disent abandonnés et bien cette
politique monétaire la fait s'effondrer
la valeur d'un billet de banque il a
encore une fois vous tombez dans
l'hyperinflation elle assez délétère et
vous autres tombées dans des récessions
sanglante hyperinflation que les gens
comprennent bien et dire que pour tout
ce qu'ils ont
eh bien ça veut dire tout ce qu'ils
avaient ne vaut plus rien donc c'est
l'hymne du flux versus du stock dire
qu'en gros tous ceux qui seront en plus
plus seniors et feront pas la capacité à
être productif et bien subiront de plein
fouet tout cela dans attention et c'est
déjà arrivé dans le passé mais le
problème et c'est pour ça que j'essaie
complexe attention c'est pas parce qu'on
monte à 230 qu'on survit à 260 ans
montera tête à 300 la question de la
question c'est pas de savoir est ce que
oui nous sommes là factuellement la
question c'est est-ce que ça va avoir
comme conséquence à terme et le risque
principal clfc l'hyperinflation à
travers la perte de confiance dans la
valeur de la monnaie du billet de banque
n'est pas autre chose qu'un contrat de
confiance entre les concitoyens et les
entreprises acceptent d'échanger entre
eux et ce sera le mot de la fin merci à
beaucoup pierre sabatier d'avoir été
parmi nous dans cette émission je
rappelle que vous êtes économiste membre
d econoclaste et président du cabinet
preview folie vie est question cash
premier commentaire celui de bulles
tikis temps un bon moyen pour faire
baisser la facture d'énergie es7 baisser
les taxes oui
rien à ajouter non mon père ça aux
commentaires de jack la transition
énergétique ne me semble pas très
cohérente car on y met beaucoup trop de
restrictions à la consommation est très
peu de financement pour la recherche et
le développement énergétique
oui c'est en fait on s'aperçoit que les
les les énergies renouvelables sont en
très grande partie
viennent de pays comme la chine les
panneaux solaires les
certains composants des éoliennes donc
oui on a un peu qu'ils sont fabriqués en
france mais la grosse majorité des
choses vient de l'étranger et vous avez
en plus
des choses qui
alors sont acceptés daisy unanimement
donc on vous met des éoliennes parts aux
extras sans penser une seconde que ça un
rendement énergétique qui est
catastrophique ça fonctionne 20% du
temps donc ça n'a absolument aucun
intérêt sauf à enrichir certains groupes
qui s'amusent à mettre des éoliennes
partout et qui sont subventionnées pour
ça et donc ils gagnent beaucoup d'argent
donc comment devenir millionnaire
rapidement et bien vous mettez des
éoliennes et et vous est sponsorisé par
toute la population française c'est bien
c'est intéressant mais ça ne fait pas
avancer le schmilblic est en revanche
vous n'avez il ça depuis des années est
absolument rien qui est mis pour par
exemple je ne sais pas
maîtriser un peu mieux le traitement des
déchets nucléaires par exemple ça
pourrait être intéressant à faire mais
non on préfère je vous dis subventionner
des éoliennes qui servent à rien donc
voilà yab ya beaucoup de choses à dire
oui sur cette transition énergétique
parce que c'est comme tout le reste
s'est jamais pensé avant
c'est jamais il n'y a jamais aucune
vision si vous voulez des choses donc il
ya une espèce de mode à un moment donc
c'est tout électrique on se précipite
vers la voiture tout est fait sans
jamais
en 2030 par exemple oui france 2030 il
ya beaucoup à dire on a fait une
émission il ya pas très longtemps
d'ailleurs sur france 2030 et nicolas
meilhan vous a dit ce qu'il en pensait
donc je reviendrai pas là-dessus non
l'eia a aujourd'hui de vraies politiques
excusez moi mais où vient de fermer une
centrale nucléaire ensuite vous avez
monsieur m'a conquis en fin de mandat
s'aperçoit que peut-être ça serait
intelligent de mettre deux ou trois d'en
construire deux ou trois qui ne seront
construits que dans 15 ans donc bien
après monsieur macron il aura disparu
ddd télévision depuis longtemps donc
c'est toujours facile d'annoncer des
investissements que les autres feront et
pas vous merci à olivier c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de votre fidélité
prochain rendez-vous à la semaine
prochaine en attendant n'oubliez pas de
réagir à cette émission sur les réseaux
sociaux avec le hashtag rt cash on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine et on se
quitte avec votre mot de la fin bien je
disais en début d'émission que on allait
vous montrer qu'un effet de levier
pouvait se transformer en effet massue
et bien je pense que la dette est en
effet un coup de massue
plus tard mais un coup de massue tout de
même